avec nous dr karl weiss dr weiss bonsoir
alors d'abord comment ça se passe dans
votre hôpital qu'elle les échos vous
avez peut-être ailleurs aussi mais parce
que l'on disait oui à plus de cas mais
c'est des jeunes et sont pas malades
là on voit les geeks commencé à bouger
malheureusement et il ya davantage
d'hospitalisations le sentez vous le
voyez vous on sent qu'il ya des
hospitalisations qui augmente c'est
clair net et précis on a des
hospitalisations dans les unités trop
intensif avec des patients plus jeunes
que durant la dernière vague et on n'a
par contre pas une augmentation très
importante du nombre d'hospitalisations
on est très loin du pic de la première
vague mais on sait que la deuxième vague
ne sera pas comme la première pour
beaucoup de raisons la première chose
importante qu'il va falloir souligner
c'est que dans la deuxième vague on ne
pourra pas faire ce qu'on a fait durant
la première vague
c'est à dire de complètement fermé le
système pour tout le reste il faut qu'on
continue de travailler qu'on continue de
donner des soins pour tous les gens qui
ont des pathologies autre que de lakovic
19 donc il faut continuer son ensemble
fait bien actuellement tâche peut pas
parler propre système et je veux parler
pour mon hôpital où les gens là les
chirurgies les admissions pour sortes de
choses continuent par contre il ya c'est
que on s'aperçoit que les gens qui sont
actuellement c'est ce n'est pas du tout
les sens de soins prolongés ce n'est pas
le groupe de personnes âgées c'est pas
des gens qui ont des problèmes multiples
et très âgées ce sont des gens beaucoup
plus jeunes pour la plupart et pour
certains qui ont même pas de facteur de
risque
mais qu'on a mais avec des maladies plus
sévères et c'est un peu nous évidemment
la pointe de l'iceberg c'est à dire que
même si vous vous dites que 1% des gens
jeunes et en bonne santé vont trouver
très malade mais 1% de 2000 personnes va
écouter ça fait quand même dix personnes
alors c'est comme ça qu'il faut voir les
choses donc au québec on aura
l'opportunité d'écrire notre propre
scénario est ce qu'on veut avoir
cinquante mille personnes de malades
rhin pour s'en vont et très malade ou
est-ce qu'on veut avoir cinq cent mille
personnes de malades dont un pour cent
vont être très malin
c'est la différence de nombre
mathématiques qui va être non la
surcharge du système mais par effet
domino ne craignez-vous pas par ailleurs
que des gens plus faibles puis on l'a vu
à laval on a commencé notre bulletin
avec ça aujourd'hui à laval et un centre
pour personnes âgées où il ya vingt cas
neuf ont été transférés à l'hôpital à la
cité de la santé à laval
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas exclure que
le virus va pouvoir se ré inflitrés dans
les lieux et des gens qui sont plus
fragiles
c'est sûr qu'il va se tient un filtre et
je pense que penser le contraire à
l'échelle du québec est utopique c'est
clair net et précis qu on va
certainement avoir des éclosions dans
des endroits qui vont et des centres
pour personnes âgées mais on ne
connaîtra pas ce qu'on a vu durant la
première vague rock la dynamique
l'épidémiologie et différent ça fait des
semaines que on le répète ça on dit que
ce sont des gens beaucoup plus jeunes
beaucoup plus mobile parce qu'ils sont
plus jeunes justement vous l'exemple
classique c'est ce qui est arrivé dans
le bas-du-fleuve donc des gens qui se
sont promenés d'une ville à l'autre
donc à partir du moment où vous avez des
gens beaucoup plus jeunes capables de se
promener beaucoup capable d'avoir aussi
beaucoup plus de contacts parce qu'ils
sont justement plus mobiles sont plus
actifs ils ont plus de liens sociaux
donc la transmission à ce niveau là va
se faire beaucoup et qu'il va y avoir
une espèce d'effet à d'atteinte
secondaire des contacts de ces gens là
et dans les compacts il va y avoir des
grands parents il va y avoir des parents
qui vont être malade avec des maladies
sous jacentes il va y avoir des
collègues de travail est malade avec des
maladies sous jacentes et c'est ça qui
va être un petit peu comme vous l'avez
mentionné le fait qu'un certain moment
on va se retrouver tout à fait avec des
gens plus à risque ils vont suivons un
communiqué mais bon sang vous n'êtes pas
dans un temps de réseau des résidences
pour personnes âgées mais est-ce que
vous avez la nette impression qu on est
malgré tout mieux préparé ne serait ce
que parce qu'il ya du matériel de
protection pour les employés il ya des
zones rouges à des zones froides ça déjà
c'est un pote ga par rapport à la
première vague pour ça vous dit ça ne
peut pas être aussi dramatique mais à
écouter la première banque on est parti
de zéro alors on pouvait que s'améliorer
donc il faut partir de ce principe là
donc c'est clair que là on a du matériel
là on est parti en un an les gens sont
préparés et les gens sont mieux
entraîner les gens il ya eu de gros
efforts qui ont été faits il ya des gens
on a recruté du monde aussi dans l'est
dans les centres de soins prolongés par
l'intermédaire des sinus vous savez on
travaille on et moi je ferai dans un si
ce oui je suis à l'hôpital général juif
qui est le sens du silice en termes de
soins aigus mais il ya beaucoup de soins
chroniques qui sont rattachés à
l'hôpital donc on voit les personnes
âgées on voit par mes collègues font de
la prévention et du contrôle des
infections mais me les microbiologistes
infectiologues
je le sais par tous mes collègues à
travers la province qui en font comment
la préparation est beaucoup plus je vous
dirais travailler beaucoup plus soutenue
dans les centres de personnes âgées donc
ça veut pas dire qu'on n'aura pas
d'éclosion
mais on ne rencontrera pas heureusement
ce qu'on a vécu durant la première vague
non mais la deuxième vague pourrait être
très différente parce qu'elle a un
visage différent et elle pourrait nous
causer d'autres problèmes
et là c'est une question de société oui
parce que c'est la loi du nombre
comme vous avez dit comme il ya de la
transmission communautaire les gens la
plupart la grande majorité des gens sont
pas malades mais comme il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de gens qui seront atteintes il
y en a eu 1 pour ça qu'ils pour qui ils
devront aller vous rendre visite et à
d'autres hôpitaux psy tout à fait et
puis il faut voir aussi qu'il ya une
différence majeure avec la première
vague la première vague a été très
centré sur l'île de montréal et la
périphérie immédiate de montréal
donc les régions ont été épargnées
québec a été épargné par la première
vague alors que là vous voyez qu'il ya
de multiples d'éclosion dans de
multiples régions
ce qui fait dire que la dynamique encore
une fois est très différente on voit que
le bas saint laurent a eu plus de cas
ces dernières semaines que depuis le
début de la pandémie québec qui a été
peu affectée je parle à mes collègues de
thé ben heck plusieurs fois par jour et
pire
je sais que le nombre de cas augmente à
québec dont donc il ya la même chose on
voit qu'en mauricie commence à avoir des
cas également
donc on voit qu'il ya plus de 2,4 qui
sont hospitalisés un peu partout et ça
c'est très différent de là
et de ce qu'on a vu durant la première
vague était d'abord montréal et centres
de soins prolongés d'accord dr weiss est
ce que on fait face aux mêmes virus oui
on fasse exactement où même des russes
nous on a appris beaucoup sur la façon
de traiter les malades surtout les gens
très sévère on sait ce qui marche pas on
sait ce qui marche
on sait qu'il ya des choses qui sont par
affaires et des choses qu'on doit faire
par contre donc on a appris cet aspect
là pour les quatre essais vers les cages
dire est assez sévère est ce qu'on va
hospitalisé ce qu'on sait pas par contre
c'est on n'a pas encore vaccin on n'a
pas de médicaments qui est vraiment
efficace pour la comique 19 c'est à dire
on n'a pas un antiviral comme on a eu
par exemple pour l'influenza dans le
passé mon enfant est un antiviral qu'on
peut donner on va dire mon dieu c'est un
traitement miraculeux tout ce qui est
sorti à date je dirais des effets plutôt
mitigé peut-être un petit peu étant il
ya des choses qu'on a appris et on sait
que les stéroïdes par exemple sont très
utiles pour les 15 et 20 on sait mieux
ventiler les gens on s'est donné
certains types de mal que de molécules
pour diminuer l'inflammation s'est
améliorée est-ce qu'en vingt secondes
pour m'expliquer si cette controverse
sur les aérosols est ce que on est dans
une pièce et les gens qui bon kit ou sur
le ca
dans le deux mètres mais que les
particules de virus peut rester
plusieurs un teint important et donc
effectué toute la pièce
on en est où le scientifiquement avec ça
mais c'est sûr qu'il ya une certaine
transmission qui peut se faire par pas
seulement des gouttelettes même le
concept des gouttelettes
c'est un concept qui est quand même qui
date de plus de 60 ans 81 ans qui doit
être un peu remis en question la
transmission principale se fait encore
parler vous plaît d'où l'importance de
garder la peu près de trois mètres de
distance
d'où l'importance de garder des marges
ou de garder découvre visage mais il
peut y avoir wing transmission haute par
aérosol par système de ventilation c'est
beaucoup plus rare mais ça peut arriver
très bientôt interfax merci beaucoup en
jeu ça on va se parler c'est comme ça
merci beaucoup avait choisi bonne chance